hong kong está retirando de sus
universidades todos los monumentos en
memoria de las víctimas de tiananmen lo
está haciendo además con nocturnidad y
alevosía' aprovechando también el
periodo vacacional para evitar las
protestas la universidad china de hong
kong ha amanecido hoy sin su diosa de la
libertad una réplica de la escultura que
habían levantado los estudiantes durante
aquellas tumultuosa semanas de 1989 que
terminaron con la entrada de los tanques
la universidad del inan tampoco cuenta
hoy con una escultura de temática
similar el día anterior había sido
retirado el icónico pilar de la
vergüenza que había estado en la
universidad de hong kong desde 1997
todos los centros han alegado vaporosas
razones sobre riesgos de seguridad
tianamen es un tabú en toda china pero
en hong kong era recordado cada año con
las vigilias multitudinarias en el
parque victoria al gobierno las prohibió
dos años atrás alegando comprensibles
restricciones en tiempos de pandemia
pero es mucho más difícil culpar al
coronavirus de la retirada de monumentos